my freshman year of college I cheated on
a final and this is that story okay
before we start cheating might be a
strong word actually maybe it's not I'll
leave that up to all of you okay here we
go so I was home on a little break from
school
nothing holiday-related just a weekend
at my parents house it was Sunday and I
was leaving that night to fly back to
school my point being school and home
were not close to each other if I'm
being honest it's a little tough to go
to school in a place that's why from
home especially if you're someone like
me who gets homesick from time to time
anyways it was end of April spring
semester was winding down
aka final season the pressure was on I'm
gonna be bold here I'd classify myself
as an intelligent person now when I say
that what I call myself a genius I don't
think I would would I call myself dumb I
don't think I would and I like school I
like learning so I'm not really sure
what came over me on that fateful day
before I knew it I was heading back to
school on that Sunday night I had a
final the very next morning Monday
morning for whatever reason before I
even left my parents house I thought to
myself I'm not taking that test tomorrow
I'm gonna email my teacher now tell him
my flight got canceled and I could take
it later that week my thought was I
could buy myself a couple extra days and
get ready for the test in my own time it
was a slam dunk
I've guaranteed a sure-fire plan maybe I
was a genius I sent the email got on to
my very not canceled flight and went
back to school I'm feeling good real
slick until I get back to my dorm
there's a reply to my email hi Bridget
perfectly acceptable greeting no problem
sorry to hear about your flight just
bring me proof of your new flight and
we'll be
good how did this happen
this was supposed to be an easy plan
okay okay okay
just calm down I have no choice but to
own up to my mistakes and face the
situation that I've created oh oh and
hear me out I look up I don't know a
template for a plane ticket create a
fake boarding pass to present to my
professor I was in too deep
I couldn't confess this became operation
fake ticket we arranged a new time for
me to take the final that's a few days
away
I needed to craft something that was
believable actually more than believable
authentic he's a smart guy he's a
college professor he could probably look
up if a flight was real so I just needed
to make it seem like I was all in that
flight I was starting to feel like I was
a character on lost somehow after days
of studying and terrifying nights of
dreams of expulsion I completed both
tasks not only was I ready for my final
I was ready for the greatest trick I
never pull it was the day of the test I
walk into his classroom my heart is
pounding out of my chest there he is
we're trying to figure out what he's
thinking so far he seems oddly calm I
think I'm ready for this test and oh
here's the airline information you asked
for I hand over the goods he looks them
over briefly and sets them down
internally I'm like and that's how it's
done baby we just pulled this off okay
cool so while you take the test I'll
just give the airline a call to make
sure you were on the flight
excuse me I'm surprised they didn't just
burst into flames right then and there
yeah no of course that sounds good I'm
trying to play it cool he hands over the
test I take a seat at a desk in his
classroom my life it was over this is it
this is how it ends he leaves the room I
take the test oddly enough he never
returns
I leave my finished tests on his desk
leave the classroom
never look back do you have any idea how
hard it is to focus on a test when your
teacher is trying to catch you in a lie
I could feel my brain melting I sprint
back to my dorm collect all my friends
explain the new development in the saga
I feel like you can't just call an
airline and get that information says
one of my smart friends yeah yeah that
makes sense for whatever reason I had my
friend call instead of me and asked the
airline if my name came up in a flight
manifest they wouldn't give the
information out dee-lightful
nice try buddy I did it there's no way
he could call me out of my fake plane
ticket now and guess what a week or so
later I found out I got an a on that
test this wasn't all for nothing heads
up the craziest part of the story hasn't
even happened yet freshman year ends I
end up transferring to another school it
was closer to home and just a little
more my speed one day I'm sitting on
campus waiting for her class to start
and suddenly there's an odd shift in the
air you know when you can just feel when
something is about to happen Bridget
right I hear a voice ask I look up my
heart stops
it's my [ __ ] teacher the guy that I
dude he's staring at me yes it's me
Bridget how are you good to see you he
says starts to walk away I swear on my
life I'm not making this up nice job
with that plane ticket
what is this I'm goddamn movie people
don't talk like that
this doesn't happen in real life
apparently this happens in my life what
was he even doing here why was he at my
new school I half expected him to do
that thing in scary movies where he
crosses the street a bus drives by and
disappears
obviously I go home and look him up
immediately turns out he's an adjunct
professor at my new school oddly enough
we never cross paths again after that I
think he just wanted to see how far I
would take my life and he got his answer
I took that live all the way did I learn
my lesson yep would I do it again nope
stay in school kids
[Music]